So Paul, what actually happens
when you connect your build process
to the browser?
[SOUND]
>> Magic.
>> I'm going to need you
to be a bit more specific.
>> All right, all right then,
let me tell you about the magical
world of live editing.
Say your job is to construct shelves,
just imagine how much your life
would suck without a power drill.
Sure, a manual screwdriver does the job,
and
works, if you're just constructing
a shelf for yourself once a year.
But a power drill will save you lots
of time and energy in the long run, and
leave you great optimization.
Unless your plan is to get
Popeye's arms, of course.
In the world of web development,
you'll see a very similar pattern.
You make a change to your code,
save, rebuild if you need to,
switch to the browser and
reload the page.
These micro context switches
might seem harmless, but
you're doing this thousands
of times each day.
If you now ask yourself, well,
surely there's a better way then?
You'd be right.
Live Editing solves
exactly that problem.
It works by having
a watcher in your editor or
build process that's connected to
a similar watcher in the browser.
When you save a file,
these two communicate, and
the website is reloaded or patched on
the fly without you having to intervene.
That means fewer contact switches as you
can now have your editor right next to
your browser window and
see changes happen as you code.
In the next hands on step, James is
going to be teaching you how to set up
Live Editing in three different ways.
Live on every keystroke in Sublime,
on every save via Gulp, and
skipping the editor all together to move
your entire workflow into the browser.
In the end,
we prefer to build two versions, and
James is going to tell you why.